now to afghanistan and the isis
affiliate known as isis k the group has
claimed responsibility for deadly
attacks across the country including one
at the kabul airport in august that
killed 13 american service members rmts
taeb is in kabul right now and wrote
along with taliban forces as they search
for their new enemy
on nearly every street corner in every
neighborhood
the taliban
now the guardians of the city they once
attacked so often and so viciously and
while the taliban's war with the u.s may
be over the group faces a new enemy
afghanistan's affiliate of isis known as
isis k
we went on a ride along with some
taliban fighters whose job it is to
secure the streets patrols like this
have been stepped up across kabul but
the taliban insists that isis k is not a
threat
commander rahimi leads this group of
fighters can you promise the afghan
people you can keep them safe
he says yes 100
we can completely guarantee security for
the afghan people
but attacks like this tell a different
story
just last week over 50 people were
killed in a suicide bombing at this
mosque belonging to the shia minority in
the southern city of canada
it sent chills through afghanistan's
shia community including worshippers at
the al-zahra mosque in kabul
they have every right to be afraid four
years ago isis k fighters carried out a
deadly suicide bomb attack here muhammad
jawad is the imam
your mosque has already been targeted by
isis we've now had these major attacks
in other parts of afghanistan in recent
weeks are you afraid you're next
he says
yes we're all concerned maybe they will
attack us again but whatever happens we
will continue to worship and we will
never give up
isis k first emerged in 2015.
most of its recruits are defectors from
both the afghan and pakistani taliban
who don't see those groups as extreme
enough
tasks to defeat isis k are the feared
badri 313 battalion a ruthless
collection of fighters often described
as the taliban special forces
responsible for some of the deadliest
attacks against u.s and coalition troops
badri 313 is clearly a force to be
reckoned with and everything from their
vehicles to their uniforms to their
weapons
are american when an isis case suicide
bomber killed 13 u.s service members at
at least 170 afghans on august 26 the
battalion was tasked to hunt for isis k
cells
it uses u.s style counter-insurgency
tactics and has access to a vast arsenal
of american-made weaponry left behind by
western forces that are valued in the
billions
zabihila majahid is the taliban's chief
spokesman
it can't help the feel that you're
downplaying the threat of isis k
he says it's true we need to protect
civilians and we are doing that but isis
k are not a real threat they can't even
attack our military installations
president biden has vowed to make isis k
quote pay for the august airport attack
but the taliban insists it won't
cooperate with the u.s to help defeat
the group although that's one of the few
goals both have in common
as isis k continues to grow in strength
and brutality for cbs mornings i'm imps
tayab in kabul
mts continuing on a string of powerful
pieces from afghanistan and isn't it
still jarring to see those taliban
soldiers dressed like american soldiers
with american gear and american vehicles
i mean it's jarring yeah mts those
lengths that he goes to give us the
stories that we need to know
absolutely impactful
it is very jarring to see and we're
still trying to figure out exactly what
we're dealing with there still a lot of
questions indeed there are